bonsoir à tous le 2 décembre 1980 remet
à gary se tiraient une balle dans la
gorge ce qu'on ne savait pas c'est qu'à
ce moment là et par le même geste
emile ajar s'était suicidé lui aussi car
on croyait que romain gary emile ajar
enfin nous savions pas qui est venu roma
gare emile ajar était un seul et même
écrivain alors qu'on pensait que emile
ajar était le pseudonyme du neveu de
romain gary paul pavlowitch il ya donc
eu filouterie sur les noms il ya une
sorte de supercherie littéraire mais
cela ne doit pas cacher une semble-t-il
en tout cas à mes yeux cela ne doit pas
cacher ce qui constitue l'essentiel dans
la sphère gary ajar pavlovitch à savoir
qu'un romancier est un homme ou une
femme qui mène plusieurs vies que chaque
corman est pour lui une sorte de
renaissance où demeurent et que la
création littéraire quand elle est
poussée jusqu'à ses extrémités et on va
bien voir dans cette affaire lorsque la
création littéraire est poussé dans ses
extrémités et bien le peut mener à des
excentricités burlesque est dramatique
ce sera le 291e numéro d' apostrophes
je présente d'abord un ami de romain
gary s'appelle françois bon dit vous
êtes ami dugarry depuis votre enfance
puisque vous êtes connus au lycée de
nice s'est garé à une grande confiance
en vous puisque c'est à vous qu'il a
confié le soin d'être son questionneur
son interlocuteur dans un livre
autobiographique qui est paru il ya une
huitaine d'années sous le titre la nuit
sera calme ajoute que vous êtes vous
êtes écrivain critique littéraire
journaliste et que vous avez dirigé
pendant de nombreuses années la revue
preuve à côté de vous et bien j'y habite
évidemment un créateur un grand créateur
un romancier il s'agit de michel
tournier l'académie goncourt
et puis enfin il me semblait qu'il
fallait ce soir sur ce plateau aussi la
présence d'un psychanalyste il s'agit de
gérard mandel vous avez vous-même publié
plusieurs livres le dernier paru il ya
quelques semaines
prédiction stoxx use it enquête par un
psychanalyste sur lui même et j'ai
d'ailleurs noter dans ce livre que vous
avez vous même publié des romans sous un
pseudonyme que vous avez consacré votre
thèse de doctorat de médecine ce thème
le processus de création romanesque dont
vous êtes particulièrement qualifiée
soit là ce soir et puis enfin paul
pavlovitch qui vient de faire paraître
aux éditions fayard
le récit donc de la faire ajar et gary
pavlovitch sous le titre l'homme que
l'on croyait
est ce que paul pavlowitch et c'est
votre vrai nom
oui bon qu'est-ce que quel était votre
parenté exacte avec m'ont dit vous êtes
son oeuvre par exacte avec romain gary
non je n'étais pas son neveu romain
était le cousin germain de ma mère donc
je suis et où nous étions arrière cousin
petit cousin mais c'était malgré tout
c'était vous conseillez comme votre
oncle et lui vous conseille comme son
neveu
oui il a dit ça un jour il ya très
longtemps et c'est rentré dans les
habitudes entre lui et moi d'ailleurs
vous l'appeliez l'oncle miracle oui
c'est ça bon il y avait depuis longtemps
entre vous des liens d'affection très
réel très profond oui je sais pas si
c'est simplement de l'affection c'était
des liens de mon côté très intense quel
est votre profession paul pavlowitch
écoutez j'ai été agent littéraire de
romain pendant pratiquement une dizaine
d'années et j'achève ça maintenant mais
il me semble les envois telle que vous
avez toujours été un lecteur assidu des
livres pas seulement ceux de gary donc
oui c'est pas une profession mais c'est
ce que j'ai toujours aimé oui mais
est-ce que vous aviez une ambition
littéraire ce que vous avez écrit des
romans n'ont jamais non jamais vous
n'avez jamais voulu avoir une n'ont pas
d'ambitions littéraire mais j'ai
toujours pensé que je ne serai jamais
capable d'écrire un roman est ce que une
question plus personnelle évidemment
votre femme savait que vous n'étiez pas
emile ajar mais est-ce que vos enfants
ou votre enfant je ne sais pas savez que
vous n'étiez pas emile ajar et disons
que ma fille aînée a toujours su que je
m'occupais de livres comme elle était
trop jeune pour que j'explique une chose
qui à l'époque me paraissait compliqué
et j'étais non plus pas très certain de
savoir l'expliquer justement alors je
lui ai toujours
dis que je m'occupais de livres en
laissant une sorte de flou et oh ça
c'est la vie quotidienne c'est très
compliqué les gens pouvaient penser que
j'étais donc l'écrivain le penser je
voulais pas mettre ma fille dans des
situations absolument insensé où elle ne
comprenait où elle n'aurait rien compris
alors ce livre l'homme que l'on croyait
est ce que vous êtes vraiment l'auteur
parce que j'ai vu dans la presse
certains en doutent est ce qu'il n'y
aurait pas un emile ajar derrière ce
livre mais vous êtes bien l'auteur oui
en tout cas vous devez pas vous vous
engagiez votre honneur oui sûrement
oui j'ose pas parler d'honneur mais je
l'engagerais bon maintenant revenons à
la question essentielle c'est pourquoi
l'avez-vous écrit cet ouvrage ça ça se
raccorde à ce que vous venez de dire
c'était une grande histoire de livres je
suis un grand amateur de livres
elle s'achevait une des raisons c'est
que j'avais là une histoire
extraordinaire et que je pouvais
l'écrire et la seconde c'est que je
n'étais pas assez fort assez solides
pour trouver un silence juste et
simplement faire connaître comme il
était entendu que romain était l'auteur
100 livres si vous voulez c'est est
nécessaire parce que j'étais pas assez
certains de moi de faire face à cet
événement 100 livres mais enfin je
suppose que vous aussi vous deviez à
tous les gens qui me connaissaient des
explications vous employez mémoire
excuses
oui c'était c'était un mélange j'avais
envie de changer livre c'était une belle
histoire
un livre c'était formidable affaire et
puis c'était une occasion d'expliquer
les choses à plat en essayant d'être
correct on mai et est ce que romain gary
vous avez
de par ses dernières volontés autorisé à
révéler la vérité voilà là là on rentre
pratiquement dans les cabinets d'avocats
et peut-être c'est pas l'endroit
disons que de toute manière pour ce qui
me concerne moi
autant j'étais le fidèle servant de
romain autant je n'ai aucun comme en q1
une servitude par rapport à aucune
espèce de légataire vous comprenez
c'était par rapport à romain que ça se
passait et certainement pas par rapport
à des avocats ou à quiconque pour le
fait mais est ce que j'ai lu dans la
presse que le fils de romain gary diego
gary qui doit avoir 18 ans je crois non
à publier il a pu bien communiqué dans
lequel il dit que ça n'était pas vous à
dire la vérité c'était à lui son père
lui il y avait autorisé par testament et
qu'il vous avait demandé de surseoir que
vous vous avez demandé à surseoir à la
diffusion cette vérité que j'en ai
profité pour publier un livre est
diffusée sans son accord ce dont j'ai
profité c'était de ce temps pour essayer
d'écrire un livre juste pour le reste
toutes les interprétations sont
acceptables pour ce qui concerne la
déclaration elle-même
personne ne me fera pas croire que ce
n'était pas à moi à la faire peut-être
est-ce que c'est excessive et
prétentieux mais c'était une affaire que
j'ai connus par romain pour romain est
pour moi alors il me semble que ni les
avocats parce qu'il ya toujours des
ribambelles l'avocat ni lait ni diego
qui était un garçon si jeune et encore
une face à sète sont des choses très
désagréable et je pense à autre chose je
pense que si par exemple on avait révélé
la vérité huit jours après la mort de
romain gary
vous auriez été d'une certaine manière
ridiculisés il faut bien le dire a été
tragique pour vous j'ai pensé à ça c'est
pour ça que j'ai fait ce livre je vous
dis je n'avais pas assez de forces pour
avoir ce silence stolic oui bon et
alors je vais demander maintenant trois
invités est-ce que vous pensez que le
paul pavlowitch je commençais par vous
françois bandits avaient raison d'écrire
ce témoignage de raconter le récit de ce
qu'il a vécu et de le publier
je voudrais d'abord dire qu'il ya une
astuce dans cette couverture même vous
avais cru qu'il s'appelle l'homme que
l'on croyait le vrai titre l homme que
l'on croyait ajar mais la jarre est
imprimé en trompe l'oeil pour qu on
croit que c'est une manchette donc ce
titre même est déjà en bus et ce n'est
pas la seule ambiguïté moi je comprends
pas blue ridge
on voit ça dans les théâtres pirandello
dans des films de jean renoir de l'homme
mettant un garde-chasse un serviteur
quelqu'un à qui on l'affublé masques ont
introduit dans la bonne société doit y
jouer un rôle
et quand c'est fini on leur envoyait
tout à coup voilà qu'il ne part pas de
la scène et devient une vraie personne
en disant je ne sais pas seulement le
rôle que manu destinée je suis quelqu'un
est à ce moment dans la comédie un
élément tragique intervient et je peux
comprendre qu'on n'ait pas envie d'être
comme la nouvelle que romain gary et
mais tellement de pau le masque de la
mort rouge ou quand on arrache le masque
il n'y a rien il a voulu montrer que
quand on a la chance qu'il ya quelqu'un
moi je peux comprendre ça je ne dis pas
à prouver parce que je ne suis pas
qualifié pour approuver
d'autant moins que contrairement à vous
pour moi dégoût malgré sa jeunesse est
un nom mais pas monde
mais ceci dit je nous conte personnes
dont le père entrer dans la polémique
mais on peut dire il a voulu exister et
pas simplement dire il a joué son rôle
et disparaît ça je compte donc j'ai lu
dans la presse par exemple ya des gens
qui vous accusent d'avoir fait une
opération marketing pour gagner de
l'argent
ça recoupe ce que monsieur bon didier à
côté
à propos de cette bande et plus
largement des ambiguïtés d imiter et
d'un trompe l'oeil
oui bon on prend pas dans les détails je
pourrais vous expliquer pourquoi et
comment ce qui met rien qu'est une
intéressant mais je pense que les
ambiguïtés sont d'origine et c'est
peut-être une séquelle ajar ça c'est ce
que j'ai appris en partie peut-être mal
appris mais c'est ça fait partie de
l'enseignement de romain michel tournier
quel est votre sentiment
bien je voudrais vous permettez poser
une question à paul pavlowitch est-ce
que et maintenant que vous pouvez faire
un mariage un bilan est ce que vous avez
le sentiment d'avoir été embarqués d'une
façon un peu innocente et inconsciente
dans une affaire qui vous a échappé dont
vous ne juriez pas l'ampleur ceci par la
faute de romain gary
non parce que je ne sais pas de quelle
ampleur il s'agit s'il s'agit de des
remous d'actualité je sais que ça c'est
pas l'ampleur je crois que l'ampleur
s'il y en a une c'est la grandeur de la
tentative de romain et dans ce cas là je
ne dirais pas que j'ai été embarqué
je crois que j'ai reniflé qu'il y avait
un truc extraordinaire mais ça veut pas
dire que j'étais maître de tout ça j'ai
suivi naturellement dans un instrument
j'étais un instrument intégralement si
denis chatelier serait ce que vous
comprenez qu'il a eu une est envahie ans
il avait n'est ce pas la vérité finit
toujours par par éclater et comme il
avait un rôle central et même le rôle
central depuis la mort de romain gary
dans cette vérité il me semble qu'il
valait mieux prendre les devants et
prendre les devants en l'art
le révérend moi je crois que c'est
parfaitement compréhensible j'ai
rarement des laisses vous comprenez
aussi qui l'a prouvé dans sa désir de
décrire tout ça et de le publier
je crois que c'est une histoire très
complexes entre deux êtres humains va au
delà de tous les aspects littéraire dont
on va parler et
je crois que c'était sa manière de
finalement de regagner statut actif un
statut d'atelier de toute une histoire
père fils il ya des histoires
extrêmement complexe et une dignité
d'être humain à part entière coq et qui
a son mot à dire ce quelque chose qui
finalement en tant que relation entre
deux personnes ne concernait que vous et
romain gary
je pense peut-être que la dignité c'est
simplement ma petite affaire je crois
que romain ne visez pas la dignité je
crois qu'ils visaient un coup majeur
littérairement et que tout tout
l'arrière chambre psychologique
psychanalytique qui explique aux qui
peut tracer des structures dans cette
histoire n'était pas du tout son
problème
lui y voyait un élan de création et au
delà de mes motivations psychologiques
j'ai quand même reniflé que le type
allait faire quelque chose de très
exceptionnel et paul pavlowitch revenons
en maintenant la question essentielle
pourquoi roma gars y at il un jour de
l'année quelle année a commencé le
nageur 73 73 pourquoi tout d'un coup at
il voulu prend publier des livres sous
le pseudo d'un pseudonyme
vous savez moi j'ai connu d'une certaine
manière très intimement romain mais j'ai
toujours gardé en tête que je le
connaissais très partiellement aussi je
crois que c'est le fait de tous les gens
qui l'ont connu il était un type qui
tournait et qui montrait une face à un
moment donné et qui ensuite est pas
rester sans changer tellement qu'on
était très désarçonné et qu'on ne savait
pas ce que ce que l'humain a dit c'était
que donc il y avait là une chance pour
lui d'une percée dans l'absolu de
quelque chose de nouveau
ce que moi j'ai compris par la suite
c'est qu'il tentait quelque chose de
très exceptionnel et des fois je sais
pas s'il savait ce qu'il faisait oui
mais ils vous déclare un moment je n'ai
plus la liberté nécessaire
voilà pourquoi
cet ignoble parce que romain était un
bonhomme qui connaissait très bien
beaucoup de milieux et icône et c'est
surtout le milieu littéraire parisien
est à moins que je sois tendancieux ou
que je connaisse les choses de manière
suffisante
romain me paraissait être typiquement le
type ligoté condamné c'était le vieux
gary le type qui faisait son livre qu'on
aimait qu'on n'aimait pas c'était le
bonhomme qu'on enfin d'autres l'ont dit
a bien avant il était vraiment très
répertoriés alors il y avait ceux qui
étaient de service pour le couler et
avait s'inquiéter pour l'encenser
ils n'étaient pas très nombreux donc
voulait dire par là qu'il y avait aussi
le besoin chez lui peut-être de de
s'échapper des des sentiers battus et de
flou et la critique littéraire
je crois qu'il voulait flou et la
critique littéraire et d'autres choses
je crois aussi que je crois qu'il y
avait un énorme truc je crois qu'il
voulait faire quelque chose de tout
nouveau
je crois qu'il voulait un record du
monde ce type
il voulait un truc énorme et je sais pas
comment les choses se sont consolidés
dans son esprit en plus cet étonnant
secret et vous lâcher des bribes
d'informations et vous disait des trucs
dans la mesure où vous étiez sur le
moment son intime ou du moins sans
témoin ou quelque chose comme ça mais
moi j'ai eu toujours beaucoup de
méfiance face à ce que me disait romain
parce que j'avais toujours l'impression
qu'ils me donnaient un morceau
d'information ou un morceau de vérité et
non pas parce qu'il était un menteur
mais parce qu'ils détenaient les pièces
en morceaux mais vous ajoutez vous fait
cette remarque dans votre livre vous
dites que dans tous les romans de gare
ou enfin de le dire la majorité
il y a des gens et des faux papiers oui
peut-être excessif mais je crois que bon
dans ce set histoire jeu je dis que
c'est une affaire d'identité et ça
m'ennuie un peu que ce soit résumer à ça
parce que il est bien entendu que les
affaires d'identité sont reconnus comme
importante mais je crois que romain vous
savez la vie est dit
mick c'est à dire que vous avez beau
avoir des raisons d'origine là dessus
vous vivez donc vous avez vous changé
vos raisons et les choses se
démultiplient et se change
oui mais et il est vrai qu'entre monde
il a déjà il avait déjà eu des
pseudonymes où il avait absolument ne
sonne ans italiennes et 1,2 associatifs
ces [ __ ]
je n'exclus pas qu'il en est une autre
glardon lagarrigue
alors d'abord garrigues harry veut dire
quoi
à la galerie veut dire bonne je me
souviens quand il est mort à aux
invalides
il y avait là un général ou un
représentant des compagnons de la
libération et qui a donc fait un
discours commémoratifs
c'est pas qu'on appelle çà et là par les
deux romains et il a dit qu il
prononçait mal le nom polonais de
roumains qui étaient 400 elle a dit
romain cassé alors c'était parce que
c'était un général français mais ça m'a
paru flagrant que romain était le type a
inventé son patronyme
alors pourquoi tu dis hasard parce que
donc à jaro temps qu'il met les dix un
certain soir en souriant gentiment ce
doit signifier braise ou feu qui s'est
éteint ou cendres chaudes je ne sais pas
vraiment je connais pas le russe met
donc il ya une affinité entre feu ou du
moins brûle et braises mais en anglais
c'est une porte entrouverte mais ça
c'est moi qui l'ait faufiler ce que j'ai
cherché désespérément une explication
dans les gens à dépenser puisque
l'anglais le savez comme le pensait oui
mais il était le père de son oeuvre là
dessus ajar s'était garé aussi c'était
une contradiction de plus c'était pas
entrouvert romain était pas en travers
on a été fermé vous êtes d'accord
[Musique]
je suis d'accord sur un point comme l'a
dit problème est que personne ne peut
venir ici en disant moi qui est intime
mois qu'il ait connu personne dans ce
sens là connus et
vous peut-être pas que pour magali ce
qui fait que je n'ai pas le version
autorisé à reposer à quoi qu'on dise sur
lui je ne suis pas sur quoi voilà sept
aux personnes oui mais comment expliquez
vous alors vous qui l'avez diaconu qui
avait été son ami comment expliquez vous
cette volonté chez lui a certainement de
sa vie donc de créer une oeuvre
parallèle à la sienne sous un pseudonyme
et c'était une nécessité absolue il faut
voir comment ces livres qui paraissent
régulièrement été accueillie avec une
monotonie odéon bon voilà le grid 2 66
et puis voilà la galerie de 67 on les
lisait on les oubliait ont trouvé un
style plus ou moins à la fois
sentimentale spirituel profond
superficielle tout ce qu'on voulait mais
on disait voilà on sait ce que c'est que
gary au point que quand l art publie un
roman qui datait de 25 ans les couleurs
du jour presque intégralement sur le
nouveau titre les clauses lyrique tout
le monde en a parlé comme d'un nouveau
roman il m'a montré il ya un an à zurich
quarante ou cinquante compte-rendu
personne n'a remarqué que c'était le
même roman deux fois je ne sais même pas
si son éditeur le sait dans un article
sur lui que j'ai donc dans le monde hier
on ne le savait pas non plus donc on
peut dire ou bien il n'écrivait pas des
romans suffisamment individualisée ou
bien la critique n'y prêtais pas
attention mais voyait une espèce de
production de séries avec hager on l'a
prêté attention
michel tournay comment expliquez vous
qui êtes créateur comment se fait-il que
tout d'un coup
gary veuille changer de nom changeait de
l'échangé de poser le problème du second
souffle et alors que ce qui me frappe
dans son cas c'est sa réussite
prenez le cas de jean giono et bien
supposer que au lendemain de la guerre
jean giono et publier sous un autre nom
le hussard sur le toit le roi sans
divertissement
je suis sûr que la plupart des lecteurs
des critiques n'aurait pas raf et le
rapprochement avec les romans
d'avant-guerre de jean giono and
beaumugne le chant du monde et c'est là
il y avait vraiment une réussite dans le
renouvellement
gary était beaucoup plus loin parce que
il a joué le jeu mais à fond et alors
moi ce que je voudrais bien souligner
quand même il ya un monde atroce ignoble
qu'on a prononcé le mot canule
ar je trouve ça inacceptable parce que
n'est ce pas dans cette affaire il ya
quand même deux choses qui est vu d'un
sa valeur et sa gravité et d'une part le
suicide et je pense qu'on ne peut pas
dissocier le suicide devant gary de
cette affaire parce que c'est vraiment
ça découle du même personnage et puis la
réussite littéraire car les oeuvres
d'emile ajar
ce sont de très beaux livres je les ai
tous lus je vous assure que ça tient le
coup et à mon avis ça restera et je me
demande même si ça n'est pas le meilleur
gary c'est à dire le gari dernière
manière et qui est le meilleur comme
c'est souvent le cas chez les écrivains
alors il ya la réussite littéraire et la
gravité de la mort je trouve que il ya
effectivement une sorte de supercherie
mais c'est finalement le droit
la littérature c'est de la fiction est
bien la fiction c'est ça et c'est une
chose grave une chose extrêmement
valable et moi je l'admiré énormément un
an j'admire sa ce qui ce que j'aurai
admirer encore plus peut-être c'est
qu'il ne se suicide pas parce que moi je
comprends rien au suicide et qui
recommence un troisième coup et qu'il a
un troisième prix goncourt
ça oui mais vous venez de dire que vous
même que le suicide ajoute à la gravité
la chose oui son mandat s'il était mort
dans son lit ça aurait été moins
éclatant à vous de tête rhume et alors
qu'il en a qui utilisent qu'ils aient
continué qu'il ait fait une troisième
tentative passait quand on a réussi un
coup comme ça deux prix goncourt c'est
unique dans l'histoire de will faut dire
donc qu'il avait reçu le prix goncourt
pour les racines du ciel
oui en 56 et puis sous le nom d'ajar il
a reçu le prix goncourt avec la vie
devance voilà voilà
bon j'ai rarement d'elle vous même vous
avez donc publié des romans sous le
pseudonyme pourquoi avez vous pris un
pseudonyme
oui mais le problème du pseudonyme est
beaucoup plus compliqué c'est pas
simplement une question de 2
de ménager un petit peu son
environnement et je crois que c'est moi
je joins que là dans cette histoire
c'est ça qui me paraît extrêmement
intéressant il ya la petite histoire va
et puis il ya la grande histoire qui est
le caractère tout à fait unique de cette
tentative parce que j'irai peut-être un
petit peu plus loin encore que ce qu'a
dit michel tournier c'est à dire que il
me semble que l'oeuvre de gary lab
l'oeuvre de gary signé gary au fond
c'est un très bon écrivain tu as très
bon écrivain disent on ne voit pas très
différent de joseph kessel s'annonce
très bon écrivain avec une très bonne
technique
souvent d'ailleurs biographique souvent
des documents mais par contre l'oeuvre
d'emile ajar
c'est à dire gary également c'est sais
c'est pas seulement un écrivain c'est un
grand écrivain
je crois qu'un livre comme comme gros
câlin que j'ai relu aussi c'est quelque
chose qui par tous les
le travail de style la réussite du style
qui est extraordinaire extraordinaire
c'est le ton le contenu génial et les
quatre livres pseudo est un livre
extraordinaire également l'envoi du roi
salomon également il ya ce sont des
livres vous pouvez les ouvrir à
n'importe quelle page il ya là un ton
vous reconnaissez quelqu'un d'unique et
c'était pas le cas des livres de gary
lui même alors moi ça me pose un
problème un problème très très
intéressant sur le plan littéraire et
qui rend ça un petit peu dans le sens de
ce que disait paul nagle oblige tout à
fait unique c'est je me demande si au
delà de toutes les raisons qui ont pu
motiver et gary n'y a pas eu aussi
quelque chose qui n'a pas dépendu de lui
il ne dépend pas d'un écrivain que ce
soit un bon écrivain un grand écrivain
je me demande s'il ne s'est pas passé là
quelque chose à fait unique qu'était la
distance qui a été introduite par le
fait non plus n'est ce pas la distance
en créant seulement un personnage comme
le font le romancier et qui est
absolument indispensable pour pouvoir
justement projeter les tas de choses
pour pouvoir échapper à un certain
contrôle sur soi même mais une distance
par personne interposée
hilale a créé quelque chose qui n'a
jamais existé dans le monde
ma connaissance et la culture
universelle qui est la création non plus
par personnage interposés mais par
auteur interposés avec des mécanismes
qui sont tout à fait originaux et qui
ont fait au fond la traversée du miroir
alice est passé de l'autre côté le bon
écrivain est devenu un grand écrivain
et il ya là je crois dans l'histoire de
la création littéraire quelque chose qui
restera et qui aujourd'hui en tout cas
est unique à mon sens les chênes toi ni
excuse avait été tentée vous de prendre
des pseudonymes pour publier des livres
l'entente mais non mais parce que vous
comprenez gary est unique par sa force
sa puissance de création
moi je suis d'une stérilité atroce gary
est arrivé enfin si vous regardez ce
qu'il a produit pendant les dernières
années de sa vie sous le nom de gary et
sur le montage à pratiquement deux
romans par an c'est écrasant vous
comprenez alors pour avoir des
pseudonymes
il faut voir une oeuvre abondante sinon
qu'est ce que vous voulez c'est ridicule
moi je n'arrive pas à remplir l'oeuvre
de tournier alors pas remplir une oeuvre
de tarte molle ou d'autres c'est
impossible
est ce que est ce qu'il y à d'autres
exemples analogue à la faire gary ajar
dans la littérature française
vous savez c'est un dallas d'aurel et
les pseudonymes
il y avait un rib elle enfin il avait le
côté masques et puis le côté travesti le
côté déguisements le côté supercherie
mais au sens le plus le plus élevé du
mot est absolument à séparable de toute
oeuvre littéraire
je vais quelquefois dans les écoles vous
savez vous avez
vous-même film est une de ces séances il
ya une question qui est terrible qui
vient de temps en temps la bouche des
enfants
monsieur qui y at-il de vrai dans ce que
vous racontez on ne peut pas poser un
romancier une question plus vache que
celle là est alors en cours non je crois
que c'est d'être dans votre livre
monsieur bondy où il effectivement et
gary se plaint aussi qu'on lui pose sans
cesse cette question et la réponse
serait alors moi j'écrivais au tableau
noir je dis mes enfants je vais vous
écrire au tableau noir une belle phrase
de l a recopié l'apprendre par coeur on
mettrait peut-être vingt ans la
comprendre mais c'est la seule réponse
que je puisse vous donner
ai-je écrit la phrase de cocteau je suis
un mensonge qui dit toujours la vérité
voilà ce qu'on peut répondre et et paul
pavlowitch est ce que gary aurait publié
sous son vrai nom gros câlin moi je
pensais que non moi je pensais que non
c'est à dire là je rejoins monsieur
mandel et il ya une sorte de
distanciation qui a été fertile et en
même temps je n'en sais rien parce que
cette oeuvre ajar moi je n'arrive pas à
la distinguer de l'oeuvre gary j'vois
les sources
je suis en j'aime profondément certains
élèves de romain signé gary et je sais
pas établir une hiérarchie entre les
gars il est à jaar et éventuellement les
cinés baldy et les baux gâte
mais je crois que pour ce qui est de
gros câlins et avait eu une tentative et
à l'absolu beaucoup plus importante que
aligner quatre livres ajar je crois que
dans son cas bon vous savez qu'on
commence à réfléchir on arrive à un
résultat et puis au bout d'un moment si
on continue de réfléchir on n'est plus
trop certain mais je crois que dans son
cas romain en faisant gros câlin poussé
le plus fort possible poussée le plus
fort possible il allait au delà de l'art
il allait au delà de l'écrivain il se
mettait en question humaine il voulait
être un autre type
il voulait être un autre type romain
n'aurait jamais osé
compte tenu de ce que le public
connaissait de romain c'est à dire
un bonhomme qui déménage un bonhomme qui
est en place un bonhomme qui paraît très
solide n'aurait jamais osé présenter un
petit michel cousin tout nu qui frise le
ridicule et qui est dans le fond une
sorte de personnage sympa ce qu'ils
cherchent une vérité de vivre je crois
que dans le cas de romain pour la
première fois son idée son idéalisme
froissé qui se retrouve dans tous les
livres
gary et dans tous les livres ajar de la
suite pour la première fois il jouait
directement
j'essaie j'essaie de naître c'est ça que
je crois connaître de n'être mains de
naître j'essaie de vous dire que c'est
le tour n'est pas ce qu'on dit et moi je
voudrais dire que j'ai été sensible
comme tout le monde à la nouveauté de
gros câlins et j'étais comme tout le
monde quand beaucoup de critiques qui
ont dit ça ne peut pas être de gary
parce que ça ne lui ressemble pas alors
depuis que j'ai appris que c'était quand
même de gary j'ai fait un retour en
arrière
j'ai repris un certain nombre de livres
de harry et notamment je recommande
celui-ci tulipes qui est le deuxième
livre
oui mais qui n'existent pas eu de pot si
ça peut peut-être arrive de poche mais
il a été repris par gallimard glace
apparue en 46 chez calmann lévy c'est le
deuxième il ya eu d'abord éducation
européenne prix des critiques 45 et
celui ci en 46 et je trouve que c'est
quand même très proche d'ajar en deux
mots l'histoire est la suivante c'est un
jeune homme qui sort d'un camp de
concentration allemand de buchenwald et
qui je ne sais pas trop comment se
retrouvent à new york dans le quartier
noir à harlem
et alors que i les contemple les états
unis et vaincu l'allemagne parce que
l'allemagne c'était le racisme donc
l'allemagne est guéri du racisme
puisqu'il a été vaincue et il se
retrouve aux états unis et s'aperçoit
qu'il ya un racisme anti noir et alors
il se met à dire maintenant il faut
vaincre les vainqueurs et ils entament
une grève de la faim et on l'appelle le
gandhi de harlem il un succès absolument
énorme et c'est un petit personnage
il ya un côté chaplin est ce qu si vous
voulez ce qui m'a le plus frappé dans
les îles les livres signés emile ajar
c'est un certain humour
extraordinairement cruel et qui est je
crois qu'on peut définir le mieux en
disant qu'il échappe inès car c'est
chaplin je prends un exemple il ya dans
un film de chaplin je sais plus
exactement lequel une scène horriblement
cruel qui met en scène une jeune fille
aveugle dont chaplin est amoureux alors
chaplin la porte des fleurs elle va elle
prend un pot ale le reims à la dans une
fontaine où un robinet n'est ce pas et
comme elle est aveugle et l'envoie l'eau
en l'air échapper une larme en pleine
figure
c'est à ces affreux comme comme scène et
ça rappelle qu'au moyen-âge dans les
dents sur certains théâtres populaires
l'aveuglent était un personnage ridicule
et qui faisait rire et bien dans un gros
câlin vous avez une scène qui est du
même ordre peut-être encore plus subtil
et plus méchante gros câlin qui ad d
angoisse disent qu'il souffre de sa
solitude prend le bras d'un aveugle pour
lui faire traverser large et l'aveuglent
s'aperçoit par un instinct
extraordinaire qu'au fond c'est l'huile
aveugle qui rend un service par sa
présence on est dans l'autre a traversé
la haie et ils insultent et la chute
voyez là la cruauté la méchanceté de
série no mais là vous vous fondez sur
sur ce qu'il ya dans les lignes sur le
contenu mais la forme on a quand même
l'impression de pâlir le même moteur
alors comment expliquez vous qu'un
auteur là je vous pose la question à
tout le monde à tous les quatre comment
le même moteur peut-il faire passer sa
sensibilité son imaginaire à travers
deux écritures qui sont vraiment assez
dissemblables
oui françois bon endroit 3 je dois dire
que quand on a lu les cinq livres que
romain a écrit directement l'anglais on
y rencontre un autre écrivain il a eu
beaucoup de peine à les franciser il a
mis parfois quatre cinq ans pour rendre
en livres en français il a peiné
là-dessus beaucoup plus que sur tout ce
qu'il a écrit mais je peux vous faire
peut-être une version vous ne savez pas
que ne savait pas non plus parce que
vous dites qu'il a passé neuf mois à
traduire là dit elle
eh bien ce n'est par magharebia trop
gagne elle c'est jan rosenthal qui va
traduit et simplement romain gary s'est
contenté ensuite de revoir la de la
traduction mais il avait beaucoup de
peine avec les dit elle parce que
c'était sans se livre totalement
britannique que grâce à sa première
femme leslie blend il a su écrire dans
un anglais qui a beaucoup frappé en
angleterre autant que l'humour des
grands alors comment expliquez vous
qu'il ait trois écritures parce qu'il y
en a trois c'est vrai qu'il écrit des
livres en anglais lancé au très grand
poète portugais fernando pessoa qui
était un écrivain en trois langues avec
trois noms d'auteurs et on a mis très
longtemps à découvrir que ces trois
auteurs avaient été inventées par
l'auteur p soit qui est un des plus
grands et d'ailleurs merveilleusement
traduit en français il ya donc des cas
il n'est pas le seul mais j'ai rarement
d'elle
moi je ne pense pas je ne pense pas que
paul peuvent le vite j'étais simplement
un prête nom
je crois que quand on lit un livre comme
ce dos n'est ce pas qui est l'histoire
l'histoire cruelle histoire complète
l'histoire profonde du rapport dont on
sait maintenant que c'est pas celui de
2,2 paul pavlowitch avec tonton macoute
c'est-à-dire romain gary mecs l inverse
on se rend compte de ce qu'a pu
représenter ce que vous avez pu
représenter
c'est quelque chose qui tue au point de
vue de la création romanès je pense
était indispensable je crois pas que
vous étiez nécessaire pour faire
paraître pour sert de prête-nom mais
vous étiez nécessaires en temps que
quelqu'un d'intermédiaire entre lui même
et lui même de même que par exemple un
romancier se choisit un héros choisi
madame bovary madame bovary c'est moi
mais c'est aussi une femme c'est aussi
quelqu'un que des enfants c'est aussi
quelqu'un qui n'écrit pas des livres et
c'est nécessaire qui passent par là pour
qu'ils puissent créer pour que ce soit
pas un moment un journal est bien dans
le cas de gary je crois ce qu'il ya
d'exceptionnel c'est qu'il est passé par
vous est passé par roux c'est à dire
quelqu'un qui existaient pour lui à un
niveau très profond avec des liens très
profonds et et vous
vous avez dans l'histoire le croit
littéraire joué un rôle original et
premier en date cette création d'un
auteur en chair et en os au lieu vaurien
passage à l'acte la le romancier reste à
l'intérieur d'un cadre là comme le
patient sur son divan et puis il
fantasme et puis ils créeront dans le
cas de romain gary il est passé à l'acte
qu'il a créé un auteur en chair et en os
au lieu de l'imaginer mais ce que vous
êtes d'accord tous les 3 mois ce tableau
vite je dis on va deux fois dans le
livre que romain gary et est un ogre
il était double il était un auteur très
intime très blessé un show men
extrêmement spectaculaire familier de la
radio de la télévision du grand
reportage à la fois très extraverti est
très très secret et son personnage
commencé à encombrer l'écrivain qu'il
était bien qu'il en ait tiré beaucoup
tout en le mettant dérision est alors
déjà ce doublement qu'il y avait en lui
faisait qu il qu'il se dévorer lui même
est d'autant plus commencé à dévorer les
autres est-ce que vous reconnaissez plus
ou moins dans les héros de
les romands détroit roman d'emile ajar
un peu plus ou moins si je me reconnais
moi oui je crois que c'est dehors du
vestiaire je ne suis pas entièrement
monsieur mandela si je pense que s'il ya
eu un effet vivants c'est à dire si je
représente un relais vivants dans
l'oeuvre de d'ajar par gary je crois que
c'est une terrible frustration pour main
je crois qu'il ya eu vol de ma part et à
son détriment
et je crois que c'est pour ça que pseudo
est un bouquin intense et que c'est un
bouquin mais je crois pas qu'ils soient
neufs
je crois que gros câlin est un bouquin 9
je crois que pseudo est un mélange
absolument absolument diabolique de
règlements de compte à mon détriment et
aux siens parce que je crois qu'ils se
dévorer depuis le début je vais vous
dire depuis le début mais je crois que
ma présence était un terrible trek fort
lui au point que plus plus le décalage
d'âge le fait qu'il était mon aîné que
j'étais son cadet admiratif parce que le
type quand même en boucher un coin
définitivement alors apprendre le pseudo
je voudrais apporter un détail qui
prouve le degré de duplicité dans la
sphère de romain gary et quand il a
quand vous avez apporté le manuscrit de
pseudo votre éditeur au mercure de
france à simone gallimard
elle a transmis elle l'a lu et l'a
transmis le manuscrit à romain gary en
lui disant vous êtes un peu maltraité
est ce que vous voulez le lire et me
dire ce que vous en pensez et elle a une
lettre actuellement de romain gary oui
en effet paul n'est pas très gentil avec
moi enfin je cite pas du tout
textuellement mais je m'engage je
m'engage formellement à ne pas vous
faire de procès en diffamation si vous
publiez ce livre mais qui est vraiment
un degré de duplicité incroyable puisque
c'est lui qui l'avait écrit que c'est
bientôt une mobilité c'était fonctionner
aussi bien à ce niveau de sarcasmes de
duplicité civils que de l'utiliser pour
sa créativité
oui je voudrais rappeler aussi que
jacqueline pyatt yéyé qualité à romande
était venu le voir après la publication
de ce don en le disant enfin oui ou non
est vous êtes vous à jaar et il a écrit
un billet qui est parue dans le monde où
il disait
j'affirme que je ne suis pas à ger face
à la roma était dos au mur au mur des
institutions je veux dire parce que
romain était un rebelle mais
probablement qu'il n'ya pas plus près
des gens acceptant que les rebelles il
était en cause profondément quand même
tout de même c'était un type qui avait
investi un public très important
il avait une ribambelle de décoration et
risquent hélas gros socialement et puis
j'ajoute ceci c'est après le prix
goncourt dont cas lorsque vous en son
nom avait refusé le prix goncourt
jean michel royer dans le point fait un
écho il dit romain gary peut-être emile
ajar et il envoie cette lettre a donc
que jean michel royer qui était enfin
vous n'êtes pas son année en fait ils
connaissaient depuis longtemps il avait
milité chez les gaullistes de gauche on
n avait pas d oasis pas ce mandat
n'avait pas même pas bons en france a
bondi ce 6 mai c'était un souvenir je
dis pas ça pour réduire la chose non
mais je sais pas ce que vous en pensez
je pense était un partage de cela aussi
son sixième double parce que ses amis il
aurait été attaché avec tendresse
infections attention point de vue qu'il
devenait malade quand un des ses amis de
bruay-la dès qu'ils sont occupés et que
d'autre part il leur a signé un rôle
dans leur univers et n'aimait pas
beaucoup qu'ils en sortent
j'ai pu bien entretenir avec lui dans
preuve qui commençait ainsi bondi je
t'observe depuis 30 ans réponse de gary
tu n'auras pas vécu en vain
c'est très drôle mais là la question
déjà été le lui n'était pas du tout
donc il ya même ses amis jouer un
certain rôle était placée par lui dans
son monde évidemment
il leur arrivait de se répéter bon alors
donc en tout cas jamais su alors ils le
connaissaient et puisqu'il a travaillé
ensemble et lui envoie ceci cette lettre
absolument furibarde qui est un grand
homme que vous citez dans votre livre
monsieur je ne sais pas si vous êtes
l'homme que j'ai connu mais votre
opération qui consiste à couper les
couilles d'un jeune en attribuant son
oeuvre tout en protégeant n'a peut-être
est d'une rare vacheries même pour le
parisianisme j'ai démenti ces ragots
dans le monde et ailleurs vous ne pouvez
l'ignorer et donc vous me cherchez vous
me trouverez romain gary fantastique
comédien a quand même et surtout dans la
situation alors qu'il venait de me
couper les couilles
oui et puis moi et alors est ce que ce
n'est pas dans votre livre que jean
michel royer me fait passer c'est que
alors envoyé une lettre d'excusés il n'y
avait pas assez un rectificatif
et puis il ya répondu la pop évidemment
plus gentils ils disent aussi alors il
parle d'âge arles
il ya chez celui qu'on appelle désormais
par son nom d'auteur une volonté de se
situer par rapport à moi aussi loin que
possible ce qui explique en partie car
il ya bien d'autres causes c'est
effarant souci d'anonymat et d'incognito
qui est parvenu à un résultat
exactement contraire rendre des comptes
c'est incroyable duplicité ce jeu alors
les jouer quand même
il était fâché où ils étaient contents
de mystifier tout le monde
ils étaient les deux mais je sais pas ce
qu'il était c'est facile et il était
vraiment sceptique je sais pas s'il a
vécu ou par lui même mais j'ai tendance
à croire qu'il n'existait pas ça c est
vous a déclaré ceci françois bondissait
dans votre livre la nuit sera calme il
vous dit vous dis ceci là le rire la
moquerie la dérision sont des
entreprises de purification du de
déblaiement il prépare des salubrité
futur ça on se dit que dans cette
affaire il a bien appliqué cette
politique de salubrité publique
il disait aussi qu'il croyait au
terrorisme de l'humour et pas seulement
dans les livres car là c'est le
terrorisme de l'ue mme houde appliqué à
la réalité même bon et vous vous dites
aussi vous rappeler souvent que romain
gary c'était un bâtard et vous expliquer
beaucoup de choses oui peut-être est-ce
que j'explique trop de choses mais moi
et m'a semblé que au travers du bata de
cette notion de sens origines mais moi
même a semblé que ajar du moins après
gros câlin parce qu'on peut revenir sur
cette histoire de 50 dernières pages
sucre et en accord avec romain
totalement en accord avec romance est
pas un faux pas d'un éditeur et moi je
suis partie de l'idée
après avoir lu un petit texte d'un
écrivain dans le monde à propos des
langues maternelles et des langues
d'adoption de l'ingratitude
je suis parti de l'idée que romain se
détruisent et depuis longtemps et que la
destruction d'un e e auquel est soumis
le langage ça c'était l'étape avant
qu'ils se tuent est-ce que pourriez
rappeler est ce qu'il y avait dans ses
cinquante pages de gros câlins qui ont
été supprimés parce qu'on a pris
certainement elle vend un jour ou
l'autre reparaître parce qu'elles sont
intéressantes ce qui est curieux dans
ces 50 pages c'est que les rooney
disparaît progressivement et qu'on a
affaire à des personnages qui disent
regardez moi je suis à poil je suis
comme vous je ne rigole plus je ne fais
plus semblant je ne frime pas j'essaie
de vous rejouez
entre et subitement il ya effectivement
une chute dans le dans le ton du livre
et alors éventuellement on peut
considérer que c'est une chute de style
et une un plongeon dans la subjectivité
or dollar
ou alors on peut considérer que c'était
vraiment la fin d'une cure nécessaires
aux mains était très admiratif de ce
vélo et de ce livre dont j'ai perdu non
sinon continuez à nous causer mais ça et
il était surtout admiratif parce que le
cuisiner en question était gagnant à la
fin et qu'au travers d'une vie de de
combi sicot logique de perversité
émotionnel de tout ce que vous voudrez
le type s'en tirer et d'ailleurs ils
sentiraient moment la guerre mondiale
éclate et c'était donc pour lui ou le
monde
peut-être que j'ai des choses trop
simplet et françois bondy est palpable
obligés dit ceci de romain gary dit
c'est un grand hystérique puritains
russe le côté russe et polonais était
très important est d'abord il tenait
beaucoup à la paternité de l'acteur du
cinéma mais ivan mosjoukine qui était
moitié d'arrêt et géorgienne une fois
chez nous ici à paris il a rencontré un
vieux poète polonais donne moi je ne
connaissais que le nom et il lui restait
un de ses poèmes qu'il avait appris à
l'école à varsovie quand elle avait 13
ou 14 ans qui l'avait retenu il avait lu
toute la littérature pendant les actuels
et connaissait comme borowicz le
philosophe kolakowski je pourrais en
dire des noms qui peut être ne dirais
pas grand chose alain spectateurs mais
en tout cas la profondeur de sa
familiarité avec la littérature russe et
polonaise dans leur langue et elle m'a
toujours stupéfié mais ce qui le dépeint
bien et nous semble-t-il romain gary
c'est ce que vous racontez dans la nuit
sera calme en tout cas ce qu'il vous
raconte avoue sont ses rapports avec de
gaulle
je trouve ça très révélateur de lui
parce que finalement il aimait beaucoup
de gaulle mais ça se passait une fois
sur deux très mal avec le général qu'est
ce qu'il y avait entre comment se
fait-il qu'ils n'étaient pas
ils racontent ils vous racontent
plusieurs fois qu'il a claqué la porte
ou de gaulle affiche à la porte en
plusieurs fois
pourquoi je crois que beaucoup de gens
avaient cette réaction mais qui ne
supportaient pas parce qu'il était
extrêmement direct et ouvert parfois
avec un genre de sentimentalité qui va
encore pour le slam qui va avec le goût
même de dérision vis-à-vis de soi-même
mais que pour un français qui a un
certain sens de la forme et un certain
type de savoir-vivre de l'essence
d'élégance peut être insupportable et je
connais beaucoup de gens qui aimaient
romain gary comme par exemple la berre
camus et qui brusquement le trouvais
absolument insupportable parce qu'il
avait un chagrin il venu pleurer chez
eux ce qu'aucun français n'avait jamais
fait est il exact que c'est un petit
détail anecdotique ma faim au point où
on en est où ta de l'importance étaient
des gars qui se maquillent est
quelquefois le visage oui oui oui il se
maquiller le visage encore une fois pour
les mêmes raisons de métamorphose même
rudimentaire il n'était pas un
provocateur
il se compose un personnage avec ses
vêtements ça va moi je comprends ça en
me disant que c'est de la même manière à
jaar et les défilés des personnages dans
les livres de romain jeu je crois que
c'était des essais de vestiaire et puis
les messins et le message et l'aurait il
aurait pu être acteur peut-être qu
est-ce que là aussi d'un nuit sera calme
là c'est vous posez la question françois
bondi vous dit comment se situe par
rapport à la bourgeoisie répond ceci
dedans
j'essaie simplement de me garder le nez
dehors et je prend des bains je suis un
bourgeois libéral aspirations
humanisante et humanitaire du genre
vendredi hebdomadaire des années 30 je
ne changerai jamais j'appartiens donc la
tribu de ce que gore qui appelait les
clowns lyrique et d'ailleurs il a publié
un livre s'intitule les clowns lyrique
et dans le dos quelque part il écrit ou
du moins à jaar écrit en parlant de
tontons macoutes
bon tout ça commence à devenir compliqué
mais enfin il dit il est contre et la
seule chose que nous avons de commun
c'est que nous sommes contre contre
sous-entendu est contre et aussi tous
contre aussi avec gérard mandel
qu'est-ce que maintenant on remet ayari
vous l'avez pas connu vous bon alors
qu'est ce qu'est le portrait pourriez me
faire de lui on dit toujours que c'est
un schizophrène à lorsque vous êtes bon
schizophrène dans le sens dans ton
l'emploi habituellement comme ça je
crois que tout romancier les dans la
mesure où il vit une double triple vie
mais pas du tout au sens psychiatrique
simplement évidemment dans le cas de
romain gary il ya eu quelque chose qui
était plus dangereux et où il est allé
évidemment un peu aux extrêmes dont vous
parliez qui est le fait de mélanger la
réalité et la vie imaginaire n'est ce
pas c'est que là les deux se mélangent
et comme dans les romans fantastiques et
avec des pseudos s'éteint c'est un livre
de possession mutuel c'est quelque chose
de dévoration bon alors par ailleurs par
ailleurs le personnage lui échappe et
enfin je veux dire ce qu'il avait créé
le romancier qu'il avait créée lui
échapper puisque il a été reçu par le
succès du public qui à ce moment-là ce
succès du public s'est mis à donner une
réalité une part de réalité encore plus
grande dans la réalité même à son
invention
là avec ce risque de mélanger et de
mélanger les deux de ne plus avoir non
seulement qui on est mais où est la
réalité
maintenant moi je crois qu'il ya un
signe qui permet de penser que
il n'en a pas été il a contrôlé la chose
je crois très loin puisque il a pu il a
pu mener deux oeuvres parallèle un
différentes sans qu'elles se mélange il
contrôlait y contrôler les deux
processus
michel tournier sous pensais pas aussi
qu'il y avait peut-être le désir chez
lui en prenant un pseudonyme et en
publiant donc des livres sous un autre
nom
le fait de voir ce que devient un livre
quand il n'a plus le support de l'auteur
lorsque il est tout seul dans la nature
oui alors le support et entend le boulet
parce que pour vous ça peut être
intéressant de voir un jour vous vous
êtes très célèbre académie goncourt nous
faut publier un livre sous un nom
complètement inconnu pour voir si ça
marche ça marcherait pouvoir comment
sera accueilli par le public
parce que tout de même canton mais
michel tournier puis un type de sous
bombay les gens ont lu michel tomi
savent donc votre lit il n'y a pas tout
nu il était venu tout lu le premier nom
et le premier binôme et le maintenant
ils viennent ils deviennent pas tout nu
alors en effet en effet je conçois très
bien qu'un auteur est en vie de libérer
son oeuvre voilà du poids qu'il
représente lui même pour son oeuvre
n'est ce pas et de lâcher un ballon
comme ça qui n'a plus de plaque au nom
dans mon sens c'est pas que je sois pas
d'accord mais je crois je crois que dans
cette volonté de recommencer il y avait
autre chose de plus qui était sans doute
une insatisfaction de la forme qui avait
pris son oeuvre et le désir de la
recommencer de notre manière parce que
finalement qu'on regarde les thèmes de
l'oeuvre de la jarre il ya finalement
toujours aussi ce thème d'un enfant avec
une femme mère et pendant les différents
livres comme dans la promesse de lomé
repris sur un plan beaucoup plus général
et dans le testament de
de romain gary il y à cette phrase je me
suis complètement exprimer complètement
exprimer et je crois
grâce à cette seconde oeuvre l'oeuvre
d'ajar qui ne veut c'est ça qui est
assez prodigieux c'est qu'un homme
arrivé presque la soixantaine
donc je vais forte avancée dans la vie
et cette possibilité cette vitalité ce
rebond qui lui permet de re tout
reprendre à zéro et je crois que c'est
ça qu'il a voulu c'est pas simplement
lancé un livre pour voir comment ils
seraient reçus par les journalistes
notamment françois bondy est ce que vous
vous saviez qu'il était emile ajar
non il a joué le jeu avec moi je le lui
ai demandé il m'a dit mais pas du tout
il a commencé à parler longuement de
paul pavlowitch dans dix ans d'ailleurs
il est justement ici mais en eau dans la
chambre de bonne tu pourrais lui parler
donc même avoue non non il ne l'a pas
dit je le soupçonne m et je n'ai jamais
su ce serait trop facile de dire qu'on a
gardé le secret de la vérité qu'on a pas
su je crois que ça vaut pour d'autres
amis aussi peut-être pas pour tous mais
pour moi certainement l mais est ce que
aujourd'hui est-ce que s'ajoute à votre
votre amitié et peut-être même à votre
amour de garris de savoir ça oui wind
absolument parce que je l'aimais aussi
avec son oeuvre parmi lesquels je
mettrai aussi bien tulipes que le grand
vestiaire très méconnu parmi les
chefs-d'oeuvre et beaucoup d'autres
livres - il m'a dédicacé un livre que je
n'ai pas pu terminer parce que je n'ai
pas compris qu'ils s'appellent l'europe
c'est très bizarre c'est d'oeuvre très
multiples déjà avant un jeu aussi
différente en qualité il n'y a pas que
dugarry il ya une dizaine de différents
gary de différents niveaux et maintenant
il ya le niveau à schalke avec raison
certains trous le plus roues et vous non
je je je trouve que parmi ses derniers
livres les enchanteurs oui où il
s'imagine comme une espèce de de
violoniste tzigane et en même temps et
témoins de la russie de catherine la
grande me paraît extrêmement
autobiographique à travers cette
distanciation alors je les admire autant
que les rejets en simultané est vrai
qu'on revienne avoue paul pavlowitch
pour savoir comment vous avez finalement
accepté de d'endosser la tunique des
ménagères pourquoi comment je les
comprends mais écoutez je ne comprends
pas encore complètement moi même mais
moi j'avais pas bien entendu du tout le
même motivation folle commun la même
appel intense que romain moi j'ai connu
romain à cette époque là en toute amitié
et puis romain comme vous disiez c'était
un oncle miracle c'est à dire que les
choses qu'ils inventent et c'était
toujours spécial c'était toujours drôles
ou même si c'était pas drogue c'était
toujours très particulier
alors quand les choses se sont enfilés
logiquement est assez bêtement et que
j'ai vu d'abord une petite aventure
drôle peut-être pas subversif mais aux
dires ou moins rigolotes comme ça j'ai
accepté de suite ça accepté de suite
parce que c'était des choses qui me
plaisent et après bon alors que prévu
fabriquer un curriculum vitae pas très
convenable où vous étiez né au brésil où
vous aviez fait chez pas des avortements
clandestins vous étiez vous aviez quitté
le pays fait tout de suite avait été un
personnage et on vous dit d'ailleurs
page 84 gens de 16 ce curriculum sans
discuter
littérairement c'était impeccable
complet crapuleux et convaincant pour
des gens qui aiment lire peut-être un
peu trop humain mais assez difficile à
porter il fallait un homme de paille qui
conviennent romain avait vu assez juste
je pouvais revêtir de tels oripeaux oui
c'est très difficile de vous répondre je
vais vous dire que des oripeaux de
canaille comme ça me conviennent qu est
ce que vous trouvez ça drôle
je trouvais que c'était un cinéma c'est
tout un personnage
moi je suis lecteur alors quand surgit
subitement un personnage de la commedia
del arte et que je dois rentrer dedans
j'ai trouvé sa femme me retrouver sur
des bus amusant de gars oui parfaitement
drôle encore maintenant après oui enfin
oui mais c'est pas tout à fait vrai à ce
compte il publie pseudo là vous devenez
absolument furieux oui quand j'étais
encore maintenant que les choses ont
fini avec grâce à cette réunion mais non
au moment du pseudo je suis devenu
furieux mais pas pour le personnage pour
mon amour propre personnel oui il faut
raconter quand les choses
extraordinaires c'est qu'à ce moment là
quand lui écrit pseudo qui est une sorte
de votre vie à vous dire quand pseudo
est parue on a cru que c'était le neveu
qui disait des méchancetés sur l'oncle
qui maintenant quand on relit pseudo on
s'aperçoit que ces longues qui dit des
méchancetés son neveu ça c'est plutôt
vous êtes la lecture n'est plus la même
mais à ce moment là vous êtes vous vivez
dans à côté de lui dans son appartement
vous faites une partie de son
appartement
et puis en plus de ça vous vous êtes son
secrétaire enfin vous êtes vous faites
tout chez lui à ce moment là oui et
alors ils vous apportent des pages qui
vous révolte complètement profondément
mais encore une fois pas pour les faits
littéraires ou pas du tout pour le
personnage que ça dessine à savoir un
grand anxieux ou un espèce de poète
maudit ça se porte encore ça se porte
bien tout le monde trouve ça honorable
non c'était parce qu'il mettait en cause
ma petite personnalités civiles et votre
mère et ma mère je sais pas si je suis
totalement honnête en disant que c'est à
cause de ma mère que je me suis révolté
je crois que j'avais beaucoup d'amour
propre blessé on a imaginé les
situations germain d'elle donc il est là
c'est lui il est le secrétaire gary et
donc il tape le matin vous tapez le soir
j'ai pas les pages y ait rite romain
gary et voilà ce qui est et les pages
évidemment elle leur révolte
alors il ajoute il utilisait tout ce que
je lui avais confié d'espoir personnel
d'échec de ratage humiliant chaque matin
je m'installais dans ce salon trop
élégant et je tapais les preuves de mon
analyse et dire c'est quand même
difficile à supporter pendant des mois
et des mois ça c'était pas des mois
c'était très dur à supporter j'ai senti
monter une haine civils encore une fois
contre le type pas contre l'oeuvre
parce que encore une fois je suis un
grand amateur des ruines laissées dans
la vie d'errance c'était une différence
maniaque comme du même ordre que celui
que celle qu'il faisait lui par ailleurs
mais j'ai senti monter une 1 80 des cas
comme ça vous en voyez souvent jura
mandel
une question si vous permettez au fond
vous allez être traversé pendant 6 7 ans
une grande expérience de création
littéraire où elle était mais les ai pas
et vous aimez les livres vous aimez la
littérature est ce que vous êtes
sentiment que ça a changé quelque chose
est ce que je peux vous demander des
sentiments ça a changé sur ce plan
quelque chose en vous d'avoir traversé
se creuser je sais pas trop ce que ça a
pu changer ça a changé en partie par
exemple mon appréciation de la
littérature de fiction je crois pas
qu'il est possible mais bon c'est
affaire de culture g par les éléments en
main je ne crois pas qu'il soit possible
d'écrire un roman et de vivre bien de
vivre correctement de vivre épanouie je
crois que ça c'est un tas d un auteur de
fiction
oui mais vous avez été aussi moins
fantastique comédiens parce que
n'oublions pas que donc pour l'éditeur
le mercure de france c'est vous qui avez
signé les contrats
et puis peu à peu vous avez accordé une
interview on a vu quelques photos de
vous vous avez été découverts vous avez
dû à corte en très peu il est vrai mais
enfin une ou deux interviews vous avez
vous même refusé le prix concours
enfin bref vous étiez millage r oui bon
alors comme alors d'abord premièrement
comment peut-on rester aussi longtemps
emile ajar alors qu'on sait qu'on ne
l'est pas et deuxièmement est ce que
veut vous même vous réagissiez aux
critiques aux mauvaises critiques
est ce que par exemple quand vous vous
voyez dans la presse une mauvaise
critique contre émile ajar vous étiez
vous même sur ie alors que c'était pas
vous qui l'aviez cris non difficile de
répondre clairement encore une fois tout
ça je n'étais pas tellement bon comédien
parce que là on retrouve la force des
créateurs c'est que la fiction à pouvoir
réellement je dirais moi excessif enfin
je dis ça maintenant je crois que quand
les gens m'interroger ou quand ils
voyagent ardent moi il n'était même pas
question d'être un bon comédien
il faut suffisait j'étais une image qui
marchait ils arrivaient avec leurs
certitudes je veux pas dire qu'il est
des couillons je dis simplement que la
fiction de qualité suffisait et que dans
la mesure où j'étais suffisamment
articulé pour pas papa a laissé paraître
des trucs béant de stupidité ou écouter
référez vous à vous même quand vous
mangez de rencontrer ça vous paraissait
plausible bien sûr par les faits de
l'oeuvre oui à parme en effet non bien
sûr et surtout pseudo d'ailleurs qui a
emporté toutes les convictions je ne
sais pas aussi enfin oui ces pseudos qui
l'emporté mais ça c'est là pas rationnel
vous vous référez vous n'avez pas bon
comme il ya quand même vous avez été
comme vous étiez mis la jarre simone
gallimard vous a nommé directeur
littéraire en lumière que de france dont
vous avez reçu des auteurs qui croyais
que vous étiez emile ajar vous corrigiez
leur manuscrit mais encore une fois
c'était parce que j'aimais la
littérature la halle à ce niveau-là bon
on tombe peut-être dans du laïc plus
simple mais les auteurs comme les
journalistes et les livres des autres
comme ceux d'âge art c'est un monde
c'est une chose qui tient debout
c'est pour ça que l'art dur l'art un
rôle de
je ne sais quoi mais c'est ça me paraît
assez simple cela dit moi j'étais quand
même assez confortable dans ce mensonge
tout temps le supportant très mal on est
peut-être aussi l'argent tout de même
vous a aidé plus à le supporter aussi un
oui bon certains vont être certainement
cela dit j'étais l'employé de romain si
l'on veut parler d'argent
j'étais un employé à la fois en terme
d'image
le panther d'oeuvres d'art vivant et un
employé aussi aux écritures c'est à dire
dactylographe dans le cas du pseudo est
signataire de contrat est ce que vous
avez toujours au pays strictement ou es
ce que vous avez eu des velléités de
révolte et faire autre chose que ce qui
m'est difficile de dire ça parce que
pendant très longtemps les suggestions
scénique qui me proposait je vais
trouver très juste
et puis parce qu'aussi je sentais bien
qu'il me manipuler mais d'abord j'étais
là pour être manipulée ok ensuite
c'était un homme c'était un politique
c'est à dire que les propositions
scéniques et ces choses là était le plus
souvent bien vu mais ce que vous n'avez
pas les éléments mois pour proposer
quelque chose de mieux
paul pavlowitch est scanné certainement
vous êtes senti humilié dans cet emploi
pas dans l'emploi je me suis senti
humilié pas pseudo mais encore une fois
c'est c'est le pouvoir la littérature
mais au bout d'un saison d'année ça vous
dit dans votre livre que finalement
quand ils vous rencontrez vous n'étiez
plus que son complice
oui à un moment donné le charme a
disparu pour moi très tard le charme a
disparu parce que j'ai eu le sentiment
de voir un type qui se débattent et qui
n'avait pas gagné qui n'avaient pas
vaincu
voyez faudrait lui poser de questions
quand romain se donner la mort
est-ce que vous ai dit tout de suite à
jarre est mort qu'est ce que je vais
non je me suis dit romain est mort je me
suis dit que c'était catastrophique
super g pas penser à hajar je vous dis
rageur je m'en suis toujours fichu par
contre romain non c'était pas ajar ne
comptait pas et je crois que avant même
salomon il ne comptait plus pour main
avant d'amboise horwath allemand ou et
croit que j'arrêtais devenue une combine
infernal métaphysique une erreur et qui
vous arrache c'est l'un contre l'autre
dresser l'un contre l'autre parce que de
toute manière vous n'êtes jamais égal à
ce que vous êtes de mieux et que vous
avez toujours des défaillances vous
n'êtes jamais au mieux de ce que vous
êtes
romain n'était pas toujours au mieux de
ce qu'il est et ce qu'il pouvait être
que moi non plus bien entendu alors au
travers d'une usure une comédie qui
devenait dur et difficile pour lui
au travers d'un rap ans je vous dis
encore une fois des nez à cadets au
travers de la multiplication des choses
matérielles comme les contrats et de et
du fait qu'un jarre devenait aussi comme
gary un artiste à qui
catalogué le ratage s'achever et puis
surtout je vous dis je crois qu'il y
avait un immense ratage religieux
métaphysique on may avait raté quelque
chose d'important pour saab ont dit vous
êtes d'accord si vous pouvez me dire je
franchement je ne sais pas je suis
perplexe sur cette question religieuse
il avait un sentiment océanique aux
aînés du monde en position avec un
certain égocentrisme d'ailleurs
fraternelle c'était un artiste paternel
et il y avait ce sentiment qu'au smic si
les religieux jeudi aux juges il paraît
bien
je voudrais maintenant il faut quand
même entendre roma gary et puis surtout
qu'on le voit alors je vous propose est
donc un extrait de la postroff qui a eu
lieu je crois en juin 1975 il était venu
à peu ce soit pour présenter son livre
au delà de cette limite votre ticket
n'est plus valable
si donc cet extrait donc à l' approche
de la soixantaine d'industriels très
riches se posait pas des problèmes
notamment il il s'en venir l'impuissance
et ça le lac est ce qui se passe ce sont
les rappeurs de plus un appui sans
angoisse il s'est de plus en plus alors
grâce je vous dirais que le choix pour
moi de cette forme de finir une histoire
d'amour parce que j'ai d'abord voulu
écrire une histoire d'amour
la vive puisque l'autre chaque fois que
j'écris un roman c'est pour vivre
d'autres vies que la mienne
il était important comme ce fait
important dans tout les sonnets et dans
toutes les élégies amoureuse d histoire
de donner un côté condamné à finir parce
que ce ses côtés qui souligne la beauté
par son côté éphémère qui souligne
l'acuité de chaque instant de bonheur
qui passe et j'ai choisi le déclin
sexuelle de cet homme je voulais dire
artistiquement pour faire planer sur les
deux personnages
l'homme de 60 ans la jeune femme de 21
ans cet homme noir de la fin de la noire
qui essaient de faire resortir l'acuité
et la profondeur de vibrations de chaque
seconde qui vivent dans ce hit en fin de
parcours à fin de parcours et c'est ce
qui rend chaque seconde de parcours
particulièrement vivace particulièrement
profonde importante pour lui mais il a
plus peur de l'impuissance et qu'il
n'est un puissant oui mais l'amour en
trop dans la ligue
horie de l'occident soudain allégorie
d'une soufflement et cette peur de
l'impuissance de nos patries nonistes je
gérais semblable à ce que raymond aron
lundi notre jeu en bière ça dans sa
réponse à son génie jean au personnage
perd sa confiance en lui-même
exactement comme l'occident perd sa
confiance en une et vous avez fait un
commentaire sur la butte
non oui tout bon alors quelques
questions pour terminer et vous savez
donc romain gary a laissé un texte sous
droit d'une quinzaine de pages posthume
qui paraîtra dans quelques jours ou
quelques semaines j'ai pas aux éditions
gallimard et et j'ai vu dans la presse
qu'on a publié deux ou trois paragraphes
en tout cas les deux ou trois derniers
et on voit bien d'ailleurs que romain
gary c'est quand même très amusé de
cette affaire même si ça se termine un
peu tragiquement il dit avant les échos
qui me parvenaient à dîner dans le monde
où l'on plaignait ce pauvre homme
aguerri qui devait se sentir un peu
triste un peu jaloux de la montée
météorique de son cousin emile ajar au
firmament littéraire alors que lui-même
avait avoué son déclin dans au delà de
cette limite votre ticket n'est plus
valable c'est évidemment il ya une
envoyée évidemment le marin gary
décliner avoués près son impuissance
alors qu'il parlait surtout de la
puissance créatrice bien évidemment dans
ce livre et puis emile ajar devenir
absolument le cousin une le neveu une
vedette extraordinaire
birsa cet abcès comité et ce texte se
termine donc par je me suis bien amusé
au revoir et merci près qu'il est
sincère quand il dit je me suis bien
amusé non non je ne crois pas qu'ils se
soient vraiment bien amusé je crois que
je crois qu'il s'est tué à ça je crois
qu'il fallait qu'il offre à sa mère un
championnat du monde comme vous disiez
qu'il avait promis déjà très tôt enfin
quand on lit la promesse de l'aube il
fallait qu'ils lui offrent quelque chose
que qui n'avait jamais été fait
c'est au fond c'est michel 120 je me
suis bien amusé vous y croyez ou pas oui
certainement il doit y avoir de cela ce
passe est un mélange assez confus de
d'angoissé d'amusement je crois que ça
ne se sépare pas ils devaient peut-être
même que ça l'amusé de se suicider je
veux dire que quand on tient les choses
en main ce point pas labourer une
certaine jouissance à décider soi-même
de ce qu'on va vers de ce qu'on va être
et peut-être même de mourir il ya une
certaine jouissance qui relève du jeu
puisque plus que jouissance jeu j'ai cru
comprendre quand je suis sortie de ce
livre j'ai cru comprendre que dans le
malheur et dans ce que je pense être un
échec
j'ai cru comprendre que romain était
curieux de la mort à ce moment-là qu'il
était curieux de voir ce qui allait se
passer
mais vraiment toujours fait ce qu'il a
voulu on prend un second dit vous les
croyez vous à ce jeu me suis bien amusé
ou est ce que tu crois que c'est fille
je crois qu'il s'est surtout beaucoup
amusé d'une intelligence dont il sentait
qu'elle n'était pas toujours comprise et
qui était au delà de son oeuvre
par exemple la manière de dire que la
sexualité n'est pas comme j'ai froid de
la base de tout et le reste est super
structure mais que la sexualité peut
être elle même une métaphore un symbole
pour autre chose encore plus
profondément humaine c'est extrêmement
provocant et intelligent et j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya un décalage pour
qu'il a connu que son intelligence était
encore supérieure à tout ce qu'on
pouvait lire et c'est un peu con type
dans son amusement génial romain était
un type donc peut-être l'intelligence
lui a joué des tours clip dépendent donc
quelques deux ou trois dernières
questions est-ce que joue la presse
s'inquiète beaucoup de vos droits
d'auteur alors est ce que vous êtes
riche à tout jamais ou bien non
mais là je rentrerai pas dans les
détails mais alain pigeau mai
répète j'étais l'employé de romain bien
et vous avez demandé
oui à propos si oui vous écrivez aussi
82 pages 82 au moment où j'écris ce
livre j'ai encore devant moi pas mal de
couleuvres avalées et sans aucune
certitude de savoir le faire avec
l'élégance indispensable oui ça c'est
peut-être une des leçons de romain
peut-être indirects peut-être secondaire
je crois pas parce que ce que j'ai
appris tout ce temps là le long de ce
livre c'est qu'il y à une gravité
extraordinaire dans mes choses futiles
j'ai appris que l'élégance n'était pas
un truc secondaire mais je sais bien
aussi que sait jamais à qui je sais que
c'est très difficile
et pourquoi avez vous même vous demandé
qu'il n'y ait pas de public derrière
vous autour de vous parce qu'après avoir
fait la jarre pendant une dizaine
d'années vous me demandiez si j'étais
grand comédien je n'ai jamais été grand
comédien est là et d'avoir des yeux dans
le dos comme des couteaux s'étaient
d'abord un truc qui m'impressionnait
beaucoup et ensuite parce que je me suis
dit s'il devait y avoir des invités ça
veut dire qu'il aurait dû y avoir aux
mains et ses invités et certainement pas
les invités de nous certainement pas les
nôtres donc plutôt tous les gens qui
regardent la télévision
merci et je vais terminer par ses lignes
qui sont drôme à gary qui sont extraites
des enchanteurs et vous citez dans votre
livre paul pavlowitch et voici je
n'existe amis lecteurs que pour la
délectation et tout le reste n'est que
tricherie c'est à dire malheur des
hommes assis au coin du feu rue du bac
mais brisée moqué en raison de mon
dévouement absolu à mon métier
d'enchanteur si démo dès aujourd'hui le
cahier sur mes genoux avec mon vieux
bonnet voltairien que j'ai gardé contre
vents et marées au fil des siècles
grattant le bout du nez d'un air rusé
l'air de renato zagat faisant les poches
de ma vie et de mes peines afin de ne
rien laisser échapper qui pourrait
enrichir ma narration et tout le reste
et histoire et j'y prête l'oreille de
mon mieux
cal ya peut être là aussi quelque chose
à prendre le très beau et alors pour
terminer je voulais simplement signaler
que
donc les oeuvres d'art sont publiés au
mercure de france qu'il ya simplement
gros câlin qui est publié dans la
collection folio
et puis que tout les livres de romain
gary eux sont publiés chez gallimard
et pour ce qui concerne livre de poche
dans la collection folio
on vous a montré certainement pendant
l'émission et puis le lit de germain des
loquets je faisais allusion au début
d'émission belle voix s'il est paru chez
stock il y a quelques jours voici son
enquête par un psychanalyse sur lui même
merci à tous les quatre merci d'être
venu bonsoir à tous ceux bonsoir à tous
et à vendredi prochain
[Musique]